Okay any time now please
okay you got a plan or should i just stay duck and
cover my plan was to drive us away well your plan sucks
you're welcome
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black widow trailer video they dropped some new
scenes so we'll break it down also explain the
connection to falcon and winter soldier in some
post-credit scene theories based on deleted scenes
that the producers of falcon and winter soldier
revealed to us so it's actually a pretty big deal
it's connected to falcon and winter soldier in a
bigger way than you ever thought but if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a new disney
plus giveaway for memberships all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about the black widow movie on the video
i'll name a new giveaway winner at the end of this
i cannot wait to see all the taskmaster mephisto
memes i knew it this whole time taskmaster
was mephisto but i'll just talk about the new
footage here then i'll talk about the connection
to falcon and winter soldier in black widow post
credits in the new footage natasha blackwidow
and yelena belova black widow have just escaped
her apartment in budapest they're in budapest when
this is happening really early in the movie after
they have their little reunion fight scene that
we saw in the earlier trailer footage natasha
explains why she's there like this whole thing
about the black widow program being reinstated
by drakoff this character here remember from
the first avengers movie drakov's daughter
funny that that was a conversation with loki and
i just did a loki trailer video but while they're
talking this out that's when all these black
widows attack them in this apartment building and
when drakoff says the taskmaster in the trailer
bring her home it sounds like he's talking about
yelling at belova which makes it seem like in the
movie it's all about natasha not only trying to
stop the black widow program so that what happened
to them doesn't happen to anyone else but she's
also trying to stop her little sister from being
brainwashed and re-inducted into the program
remember though they're not related by blood i've
explained in the previous videos about how their
little family relationship works with all those
flashbacks to them as children growing up in
america with red guardian and molina's black widow
they were a family of spies that were planted in
america and it's not really explained what it
was they were doing on that mission but whatever
happens it goes south they cancel the mission
and then they take the girls natasha and yelana
bilopa to the black widow program and that's when
you see all the flashback footage of these really
young girls inside the program like natasha has
the flashbacks during avengers age of ultron she's
flashing back to when she was a little girl
growing up in the black widow program it just
based on what yelena balova is telling natasha
during the other trailer footage when they're just
chilling out after they've had a chance to escape
whatever drakoff and taskmaster are doing with
this new version of the program they're turning
the women into even more mindless assassins with
even less free will than natasha had just to
make them more efficient killers really good
example of this like you see yellen a belova tied
to the gurney in some of that trailer footage like
they're getting ready to operate on her i know
there are so many crazy theories about what's
going on in this scene but it just seems like
they're getting ready to perform some creepy
procedure on her to make her more compliant i'm
not believing any kind of crazy face swap theories
there were so many people that were trying to
find ways to explain how natasha could possibly be
alive in present day secretly but i will explain
how the movie does push the story of marvel phase
4 forward even though it technically takes place
in the past so there will be some moments during
the movie possibly post-credit scenes that will
take place after the events of avengers end game
but this whole thing about turning the women into
mindless assassins and finger puppets for drakov
to just use all over the world seems like it
dovetails with taskmaster's whole thing that they
have going on in the trailer this hyper-efficient
fighting machine who can copy anyone's moves on
the fly just like he can in the comics showing off
all the avengers signature moves but it seems like
the way they're presenting him in the trailer
here taskmaster is just dracop's puppet but it
sounds like whatever this new black widow program
is they want all the black widows to be like that
the actual chase scene here that they're having
with this bmw suv is part of that same scene where
taskmaster is trying to mow them down with his
tank also using some of hawkeye's bow moves more
avengers references it seems like the bike chase
scene and the suv scene are all connected to the
same budapest part of the movie early on when she
goes to get yellen a belova but the black widow
movie connection to falcon and winter soldier is
actually a pretty huge deal some of you probably
thought about this during the falcon winter
soldier episodes because of the connection to
the super soldier serum weapons plus thunderbolt
ross thunderbolt ross being in the black widow
movie in the whole idea of the thunderbolts
that they were setting up i think we were
all kind of expecting some sort of thunderbolts
references during the black widow movie because
of the taskmaster character just really easy slam
dunk to be part of a thunderbolt or a darker team
in the mcu so why would you kill a character off
like that but it turns out the connections are way
deeper than that so the producers on the falcon
winter soldier series revealed after the finale
that julie louis dreyfus's valentina the contessa
val madame hydra whatever you want to call her
character was originally supposed to appear in
the black widow movie first before she showed up
on falcon and winter soldier but because they've
had so much trouble actually releasing the movie
the big delay that happened last year falcon
and winter soldier episodes came first and she
shows up surprising everyone playing this super
shady person working inside the us government
even if you don't know who madame hydra is in the
comics the way she plays her character is so good
you instantly understand what she's all about even
without her having to explain it to john walker
but she's meant to be this super shady person
working inside the us government she was actually
working with nick fury in the comics she was
part of shield for a long time but she's putting
together a team of super shady anti-heroes john
walker us agent is just the newest member of that
team per the ending of falcon winter soldier
and while i've mostly just been thinking about
thunderbolts in the mcu because of that baron zemo
teaser also in the finale in his connection to val
like she refers to him as a friend like our friend
zemo got the last laugh as if she was speaking to
him in the past like she knows zemo personally
but apparently a while ago there was a rumor
that marvel had plans for both thunderbolts and
plans for full-blown dark avengers inside the mcu
so i think we're all in agreement that val would
probably be connected to thunderbolt ross on some
level if she's working within the government and
thunderbolt ross is sort of in charge of the world
security council so even though he didn't cameo
during the falcon and winter soldier series he
would still be involved with what was happening in
the way she's presented val seems like more of a
day-to-day manager of all these black ops like
she's running ops with us agent and all these
other characters all over the world but probably
getting her resources in larger orders through
thunderbolt ross because yes she is super shady
but she is on the payroll of the us government
that was part of the whole twist of falcon
and winter soldier sort of painting some of
these government officials as being just as bad as
john walker was when he killed that flag smasher
like falcon and winter soldier are the only
really good people and everybody else is just
kind of shades of gray there's no one who's truly
evil and no one who's truly good like zemo is a
really good example of that he helps them so he's
kind of good but he's not a good person he's more
of an anti-hero and because thunderbolt ross is
such a big character it's possible that when we
do start seeing them actually pay off all these
darker teams in the mcu they keep thunderbolt ross
for all the dark avengers stuff and they just give
all the thunderbolt stuff to julia louis dreyfus's
val character i know everyone's got their red
hulk thunderbolt ross theories i'm trying to
be realistic about what they're actually going
to do during the black widow post credits scene
i think it's probably going to be a long time
before we actually see something close to red hulk
but the whole thing with julia louie dreyfus
character is she actually did confirm that
she wanted to do more marvel projects like when
marvel approached her for doing this it was for
more than just a one-off cameo but they haven't
confirmed the next time we'll actually see her
if that's going to be captain america 4 or some
other project and they didn't confirm whether or
not they actually got rid of her scenes in the
black widow movie or if they're still in there
maybe that would have been one of the post-credits
scenes with her approaching taskmaster or yelena
belova with the same kind of opportunity that she
gave to john walker like make sure to pick up the
phone when i call you and give them one of those
business cards that has absolutely nothing on it
but the other big way that the movie is actually
pushing the story forward in marvel phase four
despite being said in the past is by having
natasha pass the mantle of black widow to yell
in a belova so to speak even though technically
they're all black widows like many black widows
it's called the black widow program but
you get the idea it's kind of like giving
her a moment like steve rogers captain america had
with falcon at the end of avengers end game sort
of passing the mantle into the shield then you
see falcon show up in captain america 4 as the new
version of the character we've already heard that
yelena belova is supposed to have a cameo scene
during the hawkeye series later this year because
obviously the natasha connection but i think the
idea is that she'd also show up in future marvel
movies as well but just a big reminder that the
movie is coming out in july it'll overlap with
the loki episodes so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
those episodes but everyone let me know in the
comments what do you think that thunderbolt ross
is going to be doing during the black widow movie
congratulations suzanne potts you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details everyone click here
for that brand new loki trailer and a whole
bunch of cool fantastic four mcu easter eggs
and click here for my brand new eternals teaser
trailer and learn about how they're setting up
x-men in the mcu thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!